el tribunal de casación del caso soborno
declaró culpable de corrupción el ex
presidente rafael correa y a su ex
vicepresidente jorge class ratificó la
sentencia de ocho años para el ex
presidente y 19 personas involucradas
fue el propio rafael correa- que minutos
antes de que concluyera la lectura de la
resolución emitirá la información a
través de un mensaje en la red social
'twitter' donde por primera vez en la
historia del país andino se ha emitido
una resolución de casación en menos de
tres meses
rafael correa fue declarada culpable de
corrupción en el caso conocido como el
caso sobornos 2012 2016
la sentencia final contra correa es de 8
años y lo inhabilita de sus derechos
políticos por el mismo tiempo que dura
la sentencia porque no podrá participar
como candidato a vicepresidente en las
elecciones generales de ecuador a
realizarse en el mes de febrero de 2021
en las inmediaciones de la corte
nacional de justicia se han producido
protestas durante todo el día por parte
de sus seguidores
de igual forma rafael correa ha
reaccionado la sentencia y ha dicho que
es un acto preparado para que el
gobierno gane puntos de cara a las
elecciones generales a realizarse el
próximo año según la fiscalía general
del estado el caso trató de una supuesta
trama de sobornos del empresario
a cambio de contratos con el estado